let's talk a little bit about the stock
market we have an impeached president
here in the United States one of the
predictions that Donald Trump made many
times in the lead-up to his impeachment
was the markets will crash if you
impeach me now it turns out it didn't
happen markets have actually been fine
since Donald Trump was impeached last
Wednesday by the House of
Representatives a reminder here's Donald
Trump in September when he tweeted quote
if they actually did this the markets
would crash do you think it was luck
that got us to the best stock market and
economy in our history it wasn't now
there's a few things that I think are
important to talk about here first of
all the way the market is believed to
work supposedly works according to
market evangelists is that the market
reflects all known information at any
point in time so for example when Donald
Trump was impeached last Wednesday it
makes sense that stocks didn't move
hugely on that news because it was known
that Donald Trump would be impeached the
previous week when it became clear that
the House Judiciary would be voting to
impeach knowing that Democrats control
the house we actually learned well in
advance of the actual vote in the house
that there would be an impeachment of
the president case in point
when Nancy Pelosi first announced the
impeachment inquiry on September 24th
the Dow actually did drop a few hundred
points but then those losses were
recovered and the stock market has
actually occasionally hit new highs
since that day and we can debate whether
that matters what that says about the
economy who that affects that doesn't
change any of the sort of deeper
underlying economic questions around
looking at the stock market but
increasingly there is this idea that
actually impeachment of a president of
the United States when it is Trump
specifically it wouldn't affect the
economy that much now of course if the
act of being impeached throws Donald
Trump into an erratic panic he could do
something nutty that would affect the
economy he could make irrational
decisions about trade policy for example
he could bomb a country he could start a
military conflict or he's liable to do a
lot of different things that would move
them
markets as soon as it is known that that
is something Trump is going to do but in
terms of Trump's impeachment itself and
the hypothetical removal from the Senate
even though of course it appears that he
is going to be acquitted when that
Senate trial ultimately happens we have
a known tax system for example we have
known regulatory infrastructure Trump's
conviction or acquittal in the Senate is
not going to change those things in any
direct way it's actually possible that
Trump's conviction on impeachment which
would remove him would maybe better
relations with other countries even if
it's totally wacky ideological
right-wing Christian Mike Pence who were
to replace Donald Trump it's hard to
imagine a more cartoonish laughingstock
than Donald Trump when it comes to
international relations so believe me I
don't want Mike Pence to be president
even that I think could arguably be an
improvement in some sense what the stock
market doesn't like is a surprise and so
far Donald Trump's impeachment has
progressed in pretty predictable steps
conviction is now a question mark but
again presumably we will know in advance
of the Senate vote whether there will or
won't be a conviction if half the
country has been waiting for Trump to be
impeached for years it does make sense
that it wouldn't move the market that
much if you believe in how the market
always assimilates known information
then it was already part of the stock
market level the desire and expectation
and ultimately the realization that
Trump would be impeached would have
already been priced in now the bigger
issues are of course the stock market is
not the economy a lot of people who just
work for a living their day to day is
not guided by the stock market it is
guided by what is cost of living what
her wage is doing what is going on
economically in their state the stock
market may indeed be in a bubble that's
heading towards popping at some point
that's been said for a very long time we
have serious trade policy issues in the
country that are now hurting farmers and
manufacturers in many states those don't
look like they're going to be resolved
anytime soon but the major conclusion
here remains Trump's presence in the
White House is
not the heart of the stock market
success the way that Donald Trump has
claimed for a while now Trump's
predictions aren't particularly good
Trump sense of self-importance in the
economy is drastically overblown beyond
his ability to actually hamper it be a
destructive trade policy and ruining
international alliances maybe these are
not surprising conclusions but it's good
to see evidence of them publicly every
once in a while because it was not only
Donald Trump but even some of the people
around him saying it would be very very
bad for stocks if Donald Trump were to
be impeached well he's been impeached
and stocks are okay and of course you're
not going to hear Donald Trump talk
about that other than on days that
stocks are up continue to take credit on
days that stocks are down claim as he
did during the recent NATO summit in the
UK oh yeah I don't really pay attention
to the stock market don't be tricked
into believing that Donald Trump's
presence in the White House is crucial
for a stable stock market and then of
course I think most of you know and are
not tricked into believing that the
stock market is the economy for the
average American worker today's program
is sponsored in part by Blink accom
slash Pakman if you've not already heard
about blink Asst it's amazing it's an
app for your phone tablet or web browser
and what they do is they take nonfiction
books popular nonfiction critically
acclaimed nonfiction they condense the
book into a fifteen minute audio book
you get all the most important
information and insights from each book
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month
that's be li NK is t.com /pa k ma n